when you were selling a screenplay what
are different types of deals you may
encounter whether is the the option
agreement you know which is to shop the
material so they're not buying the
script I mean there's provisions for
purchase of it but it's an option which
means they have the rights for let's say
three to six months and they can have
you do work on it or possibly somebody
else but they're there optioning the
rights and you have to be and I say
careful but it's gonna take it off the
market you know obviously because
they're paying you now my first my first
script sale the spec was optioned three
times in a row so and I was doing all
the rewrites which is good so they did
it for a number of for quite a while six
months at a time and this allows them to
find financing and that may fall through
so they don't want to let the project go
and also have their imprint on it you
don't mean so when it came time to
execute the option that means they had
to purchase the script and that was all
in the contract so and then there's also
the the outright purchase of the
screenplay
you know and then you're usually given a
chance to rewrite it one draft and with
notes you know with with the polish and
then if it doesn't quite jell then
there's a provision for you to be let go
and somebody else can be brought on and
then it's always every time it's a step
deal so there's steps you know money to
start so when you read in the trades
that the scripts sold for a million
dollars they didn't hand over a million
dollars it's only if the movie gets made
does all the money get paid so it all
sounds great but you know you get money
up front to start and let's say you have
to do the outline or treatment you get
money for that to start and turn in so
there's there steps then rewrites and so
the first draft you know if you're doing
an assignment it's the same thing for
money to write the first draft money
when you turn it in so it all goes by
step
and then there are provisions in each
step for how long it takes to read it
and also how long that you're given to
write it I mean after you write it how
long that they you know there's
responsibilities on both sides your
responsibility to write it and the
producer's responsibility to read it in
a timely fashion so meaning that you
know they can't go away for six months
and then suddenly get back to you
United mean so those are traditionally
the type of working contracts
you